Yeah,
we may not like it,
but we can't see that corruption in
Argentina bans in most countries.
Is anything new?
The truth is that since the first
government meeting back in 1810
virtually no Argentine government has
been free of suspicion.
Yup.
Possibilities are almost endless and the
incentives are very,
very generous.
I don't think it's just a matter of
sticking your hands in and your done
because most corruption cases,
they're far more convoluted than this.
However,
what has been uncovered in recent years,
it does go much,
much further.
We're talking about the realization that
in Argentina there has been a systematic
process led by the nation's own
government with the object of looting,
the country's public treasury on a far
larger scale,
and we don't talking about the
occasional bribe,
but billions of dollars that given the
evidence seemed to have been stolen
during the Peronist governments of Nesta
catch now and Cristina Fernandez de
coach.
Now,
more news comes almost daily,
but the goal of this video is to tell
you how it all started,
what happens and how this plot worked.
A plots which the very presidency of the
republic was involved in,
as well as dozens of politicians,
judges,
officials,
and as many of the most important
businessmen in the country.
This looting operations plus known as
the notebooks began with the arrival of
Nesta coachnet in May of 2003 and
continued under the presidency of his
wife Cristina Fernandez.
The catch now until 2015 that is to say
the systematic pillaging of the public
coffers happens for more than a decade.
Now.
Before we look into what this consisted
of and how much money it meant for the
origin times,
we have to answer some questions about
the real protagonists of this story,
the consciousness we need to look at who
they are,
how they got into power,
and how have they managed to set up what
is perhaps the biggest operation in the
history of stealing from Argentina's
public coffers.
So listen up.
Okay.
Kerschner is a sentence,
provincial politicians who managed to
own Argentina for years,
so it all began with a beautiful love
story between two young university
students,
Nesta.
I'm Christina Matt in the mid seventies
while studying at the National
University of La Plaza in Buenos Aires,
love as soon blooms and in 1976 after
the military coup led by left Tenant
General Jorge at Rafael v dealer or two
lovers decided to leave and work as
lawyers in the city of Rio gay golf's in
the province of Santa Cruz,
a city Bonnie,
of the way that is far away from the
capitol.
Indeed,
it's more than 2,650 kilometers away.
Okay.
If
we had been asked about that couples
particular future at that time,
we probably wouldn't have mentioned
anything about national politics.
However,
after democracy returned in 1983 this
nice lawyer couple joins the Peronist
party and it was their folks that the
career of those who became Argentina's
underwood's ready began.
Well,
now that we actually think about it,
it was probably the underwoods who
became the consciousness of the
political series.
It was a relationship made by and four
power first in 1987 Nesta catch no was
elected mayor of Rio de.
I'll send a few years later in 1991
governor of the province of Santa Cruz.
Then finally in 2003 he became president
of the Republic of Argentina and during
this time,
Christina Fernandez didn't stay on the
sidelines.
She made her career in the legislative
chambers as provincial deputy national
deputy national senator until in 2007
she arrived at the presidency of the
republic and then in 2015 she went back
to the Senate.
Yes,
it seems like the couch and has had it
very,
very clear between the legal profession
and politics,
politics more than 30 years of living
off taxpayers,
certainly something of a career.
However,
just a moment.
Yeah,
I'm not going to be not a funny image
need that you see though,
if he throws,
Hello Ziff Santa Cruz,
which is where the coaching has began.
Their political career isn't only far
from the capitol,
which after all is the center of power.
In 2001 it's population didn't even
reach 200,000 inhabitants.
It was about 0.5% of the country's
entire population,
which at the time was approximately 36
million people.
So how did to politicians are a place
that is so far from the core of power
and so small take control of the entire
country.
This is the question that many
journalists and political analysts have
been asking for a long time.
Well,
now we're beginning to unravel the
onset.
Basically,
this husband and wife duo took over,
co opted and bought almost every sector
of Argentinian politics through the
power of their wallet.
No,
look,
grandma,
they didn't know [inaudible]
businessmen,
trade unionist,
judges,
journalists,
artists,
and civil society leaders succumbed to
the power of the state's wallet.
It was billions of dollars distributed
among the pockets of those who supported
and his word unconditional supporters of
this peculiar marriage [inaudible] tell
network fed and greased by concessions,
aid and subsidies that were conveniently
distributors and which nobody
controlled.
However,
the question that we have to ask
ourselves is,
how did they finance it?
How did the connection is maintained
such an ample wallet?
Well listen up,
grandmas that to see it.
[inaudible]
goal of public works.
Okay,
look,
good.
Watch Cristina Fernandez said in 2010
for us,
for this administration,
public work isn't a contingency.
It's a conviction,
a structural political concept that
we've been developing not only since
2003 but since we gained the
responsibility of directing a
community's destiny.
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner,
while now we know why public works were
so important for this marriage and no,
I'm sorry,
but it has nothing to do with
Argentina's interests.
Public work was one of the core parts of
the catch in his political fabric,
first in the province of Santa Cruz and
then throughout the entire country.
Now,
some of you might be wondering,
well,
Simon,
hold on a second.
How did the system actually work?
Well,
you'll see that deep down it was
actually quite simple.
President Kartchner three as minister of
federal planning and public investment,
Julio Davido,
he stayed in this post for the entire
period in which the catch and is headed.
The country met periodically with the
main construction companies in
Argentina,
which in turn were convened by the
president of the Chamber of
Construction.
Call us vogner.
Well,
in these meetings,
it was agreed exactly which company
would get each public tender.
That is essentially,
they were meeting to decide how to
distribute the case.
Okay.
When everything was decided,
the tender procedure actually started,
but this was simply familiar
appearances.
The company which was chosen was the one
that this kind of public works cartel
had previously.
Agreed.
Okay.
Now comes the key to the entire process.
Once the work was granted,
the companies charged the first
installment of the contracts,
the advanced payments they needed to
supposedly begin working.
However,
this payments was given in higher lead
to the politicians.
Doris,
they can see me and go,
[inaudible] [inaudible],
[inaudible],
[inaudible], [inaudible] else,
you know,
sorry.
Hold on a second.
Where was the business if these
companies had to pay back what they
charged?
Well,
that was in the extra costs.
Okay.
It's estimated that on average,
each project's extra cost ranged from
between 30 and 40% of the total bill.
That way.
If work was grounded for 100 million
budget expansions were approved for up
to a total of approximately 140 million,
but that's not all.
Sometimes the government would also
prove changes and new project expansions
until the company that had been awarded
the $100 million work ended up charging
a lot more on ac 200 250 million and
even up to 2.8 times the initial budgets
because I mean in this example,
280 million and to top it all off at
many of these projects,
they weren't even finished.
Yup.
You heard that right?
Of course.
In exchange for this bargain,
companies paid bribes to politicians
depending on the case between 10 to 20%
of the invoiced amount.
Having said that,
have you ever wanted our public work
functions in your country?
The thing is that this thing worked
perfectly for years,
but now while it's been exposed
and did it for 700 book it,
but I said not neglecting him.
[inaudible] seizures in Brazil.
Fico,
no,
no.
Why not?
Okay.
Discovered sole details really counts
out when one doesn't take care of all
the details.
Even the most complex and ingenious
operations run.
The risk of collapsing this case was not
an accent.
Okay.
See,
it turns out that the driver who
transported the government's bribe
collector was obsessed with writing down
each trip,
each stuffed,
each building visitors the name of the
people he was going to see for the
briefcase delivery.
Even the conversations he had during his
travels,
he had written down practically
everything in eight notebooks.
We don't know if he did it on impulse
for entertainments,
if it was part of the kind of control
and accounting system,
or perhaps even simply wanted to cover
his back.
The reality is though,
that these notebooks contain all the
details of this matthew,
and finally those new books came into
the hands of a journalist who upon
seeing what they contained,
decided to turn them over to justice.
And after months of investigation,
at the end of July,
2018 high officials and businessmen
linked to this plot where arrested.
But that's not all.
Now,
many of these people have decided to
collaborate with the Justice Department
in exchange for benefits such as not
being in prison while the process
continues.
I'm one of those individuals is Carlos
Wagner,
the president of the Chamber of
construction,
the man who called the companies and one
of the people who benefited most from
this entire mass.
His story confirms everything.
The notebook set and the other
testimonies they went in the same line
right now.
I'm sure you might be wondering,
well,
all right Simon,
but how much money are we really talking
about here?
Well,
the reality is it is a ton of money.
See if Collins Wagner is telling the
truth,
the cartoonist would have received
almost $3 million a day and they did
that for that entire 12 and a half years
in government.
That is more than $12 billion in total
and that's only from the public works,
but something just the public works.
There are many more suspicions of
corruption and pending cases.
Yes,
I actually got $12 billion to pay
politicians,
judges,
journalists,
social leaders,
and of course fill their own pockets.
Everything indicates that this is how
the Kushners came to power and
consolidated their power over Argentina.
For example,
this will say Jose Lopez case,
a format public work secretary and
someone who was very close to Julio to
veto the catch and arrest minister who
managed the plot well in June of 2016
having been alerted that the police
could rate as house as of an
investigation,
he decided to leave at three in the
morning with $9 billion that he had in
cash hidden under his mattress.
Anyway,
that night,
Lopez trying to hide the money in a
confidence,
the confidence of the praying and
Pennington nuns of our lady of the
rosary of Fatima,
but this didn't have the best of luck.
Lani was stashing the money.
A neighbor who thought that it was a
robbery called the police and that's how
good Aalto seemed.
Lopez was caught red handed and yes,
we'd know where all that money probably
came.
Right.
As you can imagine,
this money couldn't simply be
transferred to a bank.
No,
it had to be paid in cash so it wouldn't
leave a trace.
It was moved in bags.
Well,
since they made so many payments,
the people in charge of filling the bags
already knew how many money wads fit
into each bag.
So it seems that the money was no longer
counted in millions,
but simply by number of bags.
Wow.
Do not forget the companies also made
money by overpricing.
So the damage to the Argentine people
has been even greater anyway.
Dvo this is the grease of story of how
some politicians decided to plunder
their own country.
If the facts are confirmed,
even the underwoods would be scandalized
by Argentina situation.
So well,
Christina Fernandez end up in jail.
Well,
I need time will tell.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that long version if he
did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends that reconsider media,
they provided the vocals in this
episode,
but we're not mine.
I'll say this channel has made possible
because of patriot and our patrons on
that platform.
Please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
thank you.